i've had coffee cake coffee cake tastes
like [ __ ] i like coffee cake okay no
just get a tiramisu i mean that is a
coffee cake that's yeah but that's not
like breaded cake with attitude in it i
need to take you to this place
where you it's a 90 espresso
i had it three days ago ninety dollars
it was free okay okay wait why was it
free my friend is a regular there so
oh well that's good for good for the
ones
yeah
i'm not paying ninety [ __ ] quid for
an espresso sorry we're not well
connected as like the [ __ ] top five
percent here
okay should i go with you i get it for
free why is it ninety dollars
absolutely
i promise
like i'm gambling if i'm straight
no you don't say anything if you're
regular you just show up and then they
pass you the glass and it's the black
glass and then they're like so wait what
about it is none yeah what about his 90s
the way they roast it where the beans
are soaring
isn't that like expensive coffee that's
made from like that cat poop
it's uh what poop you mean do you know
the most expensive coffee the most
expensive coffee in the world is made
out of this like wild cake it's like a
weasel have you not seen the bucket list
no huh
oh copy lawyer yeah yeah it's malaysian
it's like it's like a big plot point
the bucket list it's like it's like
it's like a beast it's like a malaysian
like wild cat species that eats coffee
beans and then they [ __ ] out the coffee
beans and then and these stomach acid
creates like this very special flavor of
the coffee beans people collect those
beans wipe off the poop and then grind
it to make coffee yeah apparently i've
had it it's actually really [ __ ] good
is it the best coffee in the world it's
pretty up there is it better than
starbucks
obviously not
is it better than the nespresso oh
no
nespresso in a league of its own
that's readily available
if you watched like those coffee
youtubers oh i can't handle it
it's like it's so [ __ ] pretentious i
i like to watch it like muted yeah that
was a peaceful one like so i'm gonna
make my morning espresso and they bring
out like five [ __ ] contraptions and
it's like surely this is just not
practical like cleaning this is just a
nightmare sure yeah like
the reason why i don't grind my own
coffee beans and do all that is because
the absolute mess that it makes and it
takes so much time
like i i remember i like i got an
espresso machine before like nespresso
like it
uh it actually was a proper especially
machine where it's like you know grind
your beans yourself put it in and it
just it made so much [ __ ] mess and it
took so much time
such a [ __ ] like having to clean the
[ __ ] beans every time you want to
just make a [ __ ] cup of coffee like
yeah i i bought as well one of those
like [ __ ] uh pots that you put on the
stove and you put the espresso in the
top and the water at the bottom and it
boils through i couldn't have that i
could never get that to taste right i
don't know why it didn't taste good
because it was so hard to get the
balance right yeah and also cleaning it
was so [ __ ] difficult i felt like i
was trying to clean like iron man's
heart socket my hand couldn't fit in it
and it never got clean yeah the results
are just doing like yeah and it never
got it getting down
to clean the inside of a [ __ ]
pringles can it was a nightmare like i
couldn't get in there and it was just
terrible and then it like it kept
scratching my stove because it was metal
and i was like oh [ __ ] say
and then and then it turns out when you
when you grind uh coffee beans they
expire yeah no one told me this until i
i didn't want i was wondering why my
coffee tastes like [ __ ]
this is a shower blend
i drank it for like i [ __ ] you not like
three weeks
like sour ass coffee because i i was
like it's gourmet stuff
you drown it
[Music]
sulfuric acid espresso but i thought
this is how the italians do it [ __ ] did
it affect your uh digest i felt awful
every time i did it but i i thought this
is a good espresso
expensive coffee beans
and it expired like three months ago
literally drinking water acid yeah
oh god disgusting glad you know
happened there is so much food stuff
there but it's just a whole thing of
balance versus this is just impractical
it's making so much mess i need so much
equipment versus i just want to eat yeah
yeah you know yeah like sometimes you
have time though
you're just doing it to relax like the
process
is like meditating i feel like it's a
hobby it has to be a hobby it has to be
a hobby look at meditation
[Laughter]
that's a type of meditation where you do
something like you clean yeah then i
know that yeah yeah like like ins uh
when i was a monk you had a special type
of
meditation where you walk when you
meditate as well and it's just because
you uh you just drown out your mental
state with just a monotonous task
emotion that's just constant right i
mean i get it but at the same time i'm
not always trying to [ __ ] meditate
when i cook you know like
coffee i don't know like to me when i do
something or when i make something i
like food or drink in order to consume
there's i always i always like i always
like compare the practicality and the
time it takes versus the time i enjoy
what i'm making right and that's always
the problem with cooking for me because
the time i take to prepare some certain
dishes and to make the food then eat it
which is a very very short amount of
time compared to preparing it and then i
gotta wash it as well afterwards
cause you you eat it right and then
you're like you're relaxing you're like
ah this is nice [ __ ] i gotta clean all
this stuff yeah god damn i used the ice
cream machine it's got like four [ __ ]
spatulas
ice cream machine is very easy you just
rinse it with water and it's not
so good you're just you're just bribing
him now so good you will know next week
yeah next week bring it and we'll be on
twitter maybe maybe we'll get a coffee
machine maybe one day i will you know
there have been times where i thought
about getting like a proper culture you
surely you just have just so expensive
[ __ ]
surely you just have to clean the the
metal scooper thing right that's it yeah
the metal scuba thing
no well no because you got to clean the
siphon as well could it clean the siphon
you want to clean the milk uh
you could just use the nespresso thing
though
for the milk or the milk
props are pretty good what do you mean
yeah i feel like milk frothing does not
need to be done by a thousand dollar
machine like i'm pretty sure i could do
with my finger if i did it faster now i
mean like i don't need a machine to do
it i am the machine
pretty sure you get bored of that pretty
soon